it's just too much fun to kind of look
back and the Grammys just three days
away we dope deep into our amazing ET
vault to bring you our best backstage
moments how good are you feeling now I
feel good oh my favorite
this is it for me musically this is
really super special I can't tell you
there's that second when you hear your
name and it registers that's just the
ultimate that that's musical orgasm how
does Madonna celebrate four Grammys I
have a lemon drop which is vodka lemon
juice and sugar thank you very much the
song with Donna and affront new
insightful good to meet her that was a
starstruck 19 year old Beyonce just
minutes after Destiny's Child took home
their first two Grammy Awards in 2001
what do you do tonight to celebrate go
dancing a little bit hopefully it's easy
because you know today after nearly 30
years of covering the coveted backstage
position et has seen firsthand there's
nothing quite like being a first-time
winner keep singing
never stop believing in yourself
[Music]
does it seem real I don't know anymore
I don't know I just I did not expect it
and I had no speech prepared you know I
think I'm saving right now complete and
utter shock just shot I completely lost
in the first award when I cried sorry
I bawled I don't even know what I said I
don't if I said anything I think I just
cried thank you two Grammys tonight what
do you take those Grammys do you dress
them up you put some sequins Auto
Grammys stay nice and neatly polished on
under Bantle
[Music]